lágrimas y disculpas esta fue la
respuesta de sala de slam a las
preguntas de los abogados sobre lo
ocurrido en la noche del 13 de noviembre
de 2015 y sobre su vida a bélgica de pie
en el palco con la voz temblorosa se
dirigió a las víctimas
ofrezco mis condolencias y mis disculpas
hablo para todas las víctimas
hoy les pido que me odien con moderación
una disculpa tardía y sorprendente
algunas de las víctimas quedaron
visiblemente desconcertadas no estoy
seguro de su sinceridad pero tampoco de
lo contrario es mi hija la que fue
asesinada no puedo perdonar por ellas
para la fiscalía sala de slam adapta
constantemente su discurso las
circunstancias y para demostrarlo el
tribunal difundió una entrevista con
sala de slam mientras suya de francia la
noche del 13 al 14 de noviembre de 2015
en aquel momento todavía no había sido
identificado por los investigadores y
fingió estar sorprendido por los
numerosos controles en la carretera
desde que estoy aquí es el tercero
y francamente nos pareció un poco
abusivo
pero luego supimos por qué fue una
solución
para algunos esa es la verdadera cara de
sala de slam
tenemos un discurso bastante construido
y pulido excepto cuando llegamos a los
elementos que conciernen a su ego porque
en cuanto hablamos del eco debemos
enderezarse inflar la voz y ser más
sólido también podemos ver cuando nos
remontamos a lo ocurrido en el momento
de los hechos tenía una extraordinaria
compostura incluso en el momento de la
huida y como mobile suite el acusado no
deberá volver a hablar ante la justicia
hasta finales de junio cuando se le dará
la palabra por última vez justo antes
del veredicto